- welcome h3 warriors this is your
general foolish Maximus today I lead the
charge alone my trusted lieutenant ela
is home with our sick child he's got the
cold he's fine you know he's just having
trouble breathing that sounds WAY worse
that doesn't say yeah that sounds way
what I'm what I mean is he's a little
congested he's having trouble breathing
yeah as I said that I was like well but
this morning I'll tell you you guys
haven't lived until your until you've
cleaned poop off the back of your neck
baby's neck it got so messy whoa this
kid took such a huge [ __ ] and went all
the way up his back even to the bottom
of his neck dude I was like damn dude
it's like it's like pure a broccoli dude
with like I'm telling you this guy shits
like a monster bro
yeah good for him and and just like him
I also use baby wipes oh there you go we
have a lot in common already did I thank
our sponsors nope do now thank you to
get quip and expressvpn love you
appreciate you and also I want to say
give Teddy fresh a shout-out that has a
new collection today we've got this hat
that I've been wearing forever
we called the Teddy crest since one year
ago the TF very very nice hat very good
I love this hat and new t-shirts Teddy
fresh since one year ago which is like a
play on all these you know established
companies that are like established in
1928 yeah [ __ ] well we've been here
since one year ago so well gag a little
tongue in cheek but they're like yeah
you just bunch of colors online go head
on over to Teddy fresh come check it out
thank you guys
well guys we got a lot to get to today
got a full docket but first we gotta you
know we'd like to start with the gaffs
with the ghost a little light-hearted a
little romp so here we go we've got a
drummer and church who shreds like Satan
I don't know and I don't know if this
guy is a Satanist or what but he drums
like [ __ ] he made a pact with the
devil you know what I'm saying check
this [ __ ] out hold on Zack Jesus
oh [ __ ] I'm killing them hold on are you
feeling Jesus not quite yet
hello Bob I just found God you think
they ever rehearse unclear get it what
can you do dude Christ compels you zoom
out let's go better look at this bro not
[Music]
yeah he's got shred oh so someone
pointed out I saw he's using a mallet on
an electric kit which as you know an
electric kit
yeah yeah II don't know but he starts
laughing on the electric get with the
mallet so epic what he's doing the mood
editor and that'll drum it yeah yeah
yeah it's like his band he's got the kid
on metal setting
[ __ ] yeah she's off the tempo I love
when his solos up he's like packing up
he's like peace out [ __ ] I gotta know
the game that was so metal things are
possible with God
that's right that's beautiful come on
watch again by the way Christian rock
Christian rock man what's going on here
yeah it's like you can't you cannot you
can't take a rock if you're a Christian
rocks about [ __ ] you know getting like
HPV and getting like uncurable diseases
and [ __ ]
amen to that that's right right Zach you
know better than anyone of course rock
and roll is about getting hepatitis
it's about trashing your hotel room
mm-hmm and it's most definitely it's
about losing God if I can say that
defining Keith Richards right now yeah
exactly
so I don't know it's like it's all I
feel like Christian rock is almost like
cultural appropriation in a weird way
you know like yeah come on who you can
yeah you're right
let's see
[Music]
but do you actually like I wonder if
they were a Hearst and they knew that he
was gonna come crushing out with this
nobody seems to flinch when I happened
they knew yeah still like dog can you
tone it down to like I know you're like
into death metal that's dope
you know Christian death metal we love
that but just what we were playing in
the church can you just tone it down a
little bit he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is him tone down by the way he's
like I'll tone it down this is him calm
down
and you he opens with the simple like is
there really even a cue like the tempo
of the song doesn't change it all
he opens crashes in with the symbol of
like God into your heart essentially so
hey I just googled Christian death metal
and a shockingly large amount of bands
popped up so I guess it is the thing
dude you can't you know it's like I love
death metal but I just kind of make it
about Christ it's like bro there's
nothing death about Christ well I've
actually seen a Christian rock band
like kind of death metal II so yeah
today rule yeah they're called striper I
mean I wouldn't call them death metal
but they're actually pretty sick believe
it in Christ metal Christ man oh yeah
right they are pretty sick they were
pretty seconds Stryper Stryper yeah I
guess all things are possible with God
amen
I love when he comes in
take [ __ ] back up my time shine Oh
graduates off
[Music]
his legs are going crazy on those bass
notes
[Music]
the camera man's like let me get a
little bad it's all drum fills like this
note beam through it when he does a fill
or when he does a beat he does it with a
mallet like this dude has no chill
[Music]
pearl do you have you alright talk about
Savior let's hit a [ __ ] back up some
talk about God back the [ __ ] up I love
how the he's like perfectly positioned
under the crop still like this is where
you get saved fish all that foot base
alright I love how he backs up at the
end he's literally like piecing out yeah
that's a good one thank you thank you
everybody for joining us today
shut up to that tremor where he is
crushing it at a bar mitzva probably
like you know we need a drummer do we
call Keith Dalek [ __ ] anyone but Keith
okay here's another one we've talked
about ridiculous like branded ads here
before I I'm getting a little you know
impatient with these brands who are
trying to [ __ ] hard to sell their
product we watched a video recently on
here who was it who made are you talking
about Gillette Gillette yeah it's like
chill dude you're making razor blades oh
yeah they did a whole like me to like we
need to get better it was the the toxic
masculinity one about about being a real
man
by using yeah right right right right so
so but but that's a trend like woke
advertising and it's a strange one and
I'm not down with it but uh the whole
movement in general I'm just not down
with with all these social media people
trying to be brands trying to be cool
like the kids I'm just not I find it
offensive just tell me what you're
selling and move on right here's razors
you need a [ __ ] shave Gillette cool
now here's one that really blew me away
guess just get everybody have you guys
seen this I mean Dan I know who you know
but Zach and Ian do you know what this
is for an ad for no clue I actually
peaked you peaked you son of a [ __ ]
that's alright it's your job Zach you
try to guess what this is
okay the title gives it away actually
Dan so I wonder if there's a way let's
make it make if I scroll before so it
does sure it does show it kind of son of
a gun which I didn't rename it oh I
can't it's already got me uploaded
frickin hell here I got you I got you
you do yeah I can do it from my end you
could put [ __ ] on the screen no I can
rename it okay god bless this is
probably the most egregious one I have
seen there refresh I just changed the
name so you guys are in for a treat it
still is the same name let me reopen it
there you go dan is it a product or will
still the same name it's a burn it's a
brand you know go okay you just make it
fullscreen but it shows that the Qataris
are you kidding are you kidding that it
shows it on the top left so maybe if I
cut it out oh man they're gonna see it
alright guys close your eyes if you care
close your [ __ ] eyes for the next 10
seconds ACK don't look everybody I don't
close your [ __ ] eyes all right for
Christ's sake all right keep your eyes
closed because it's still there you see
it then
yeah unfortunately keep your eyes closed
okay you guys no no you get don't move
the mouse well I'm trying to hold you oh
I got to move the mouse but looking I'm
not working all right take it full
screen there we go
they have if I move the mouse then you
see it I just watch its whole operating
the audio listeners this is just a very
sappy footage of a toddler having all
kinds of spooky scary childhood
experiences running with horses playing
on the playground climbing a tree
alright alright dad who shows us
[Music]
oh my god they went there you see that
they really get all the details in them
this kids like spying on his sister
changing or some [ __ ]
pretty gnarly
so this kid is living his life he's
living his dream it's so long - it
really doesn't get like Zach do you have
a guess right now what is this I mean
you probably saw it figure you keep
moving the mouse though I keep showing
it Zach did you see the title a Trojan
condoms that would be [ __ ] they're like
they go back in time to the point where
his mom used his condom and then he
doesn't even exist so this kid is like
he's a skinhead he shaved his head he
joined a Nazi militant sex he's arguing
with his parents now he's free it's just
it's like a little mini movie about this
kid growing up very emotional
[Music]
he's crying he's moving up he's going to
college it's all happening it's
culminated [ __ ] subway [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] subway [ __ ] subway what
the [ __ ] yes what is the intent like
what is the message dude I don't even
get it
they're just totally lost in translation
every day so it's a venturous is
somebody supposed to be adventurous dude
bro your entire I mean essentially
they're saying his entire life led him
to this moment everything he's done
everything he's been through in life as
a child he spied on his sister changing
what is the point of that his sister's
[ __ ] smoking - let me go back to one
side let me go back so he was born his
mom raised him he you know had a good
childhood he peed outside and a drain
he's out in the woods getting spooky
where's your s'mores you're naked sister
bro come on
you know what we're okay
he gots in a fight man [ __ ] life is
tough in a challenging he's shaving for
the first time he caught himself damn I
think we missed it
yeah I think we missed it we really got
to find the naked sister
[Music]
spookie darkness
forces where the [ __ ] do you look like
alright I'm not finding it this can't be
real but it's written bro this is a real
ad he's going to college everything in
his life has led him to this moment and
now he can finally die happy but it
looks like he's gonna kill himself bro
look at him in the mirror like yeah like
this is his final day on earth
because once he finally lets that
cardboard flavored cardboard hit his
mouth he can finally die happy but what
does Subway have to do with puberty like
it's not about puberty bro it's about
the about the journey it's about the
journey my dude so the journey to go
into his subway sandwich shop yeah and
he kills himself after this
to try to do
[ __ ] me what were they thinking this is
so bad it's so it's so obsessing it's so
obscene that like first of all they
budgeted I mean this is pretty high
budget yeah you know and then there
there's obviously like a media company
involved so they brainstormed like
there's a media company they had a bunch
of meetings and they brainstormed this
okay then they pitched it to Subway and
they had a bunch of meetings and then
they approved it and then they shot it
and then they had the final and they
sent and they approved it so many people
saw this and approved it do you think
the strategy is just let's just be as
over-the-top and absurd as possible so
people like us talk about it like is
that is that is it that cynical because
otherwise I can't think of any other
reason why people would think this is a
good idea other than let's just be so
weird and bizarre that people have to
talk about it and now we're all saying
subway you know what I mean you know
what other strategy I mean what I don't
think so I don't think so because it's
just way too earnest I mean like there's
other ways to do that you can be you
could think they could make a Subway
sandwich like they could have like a
dude come out the with a sandwich in his
pants and then there's all these little
kids running around he goes my name is
Jared Fogle and I prefer to eat fresh
bro I mean Subway's were already
recovering from the Fogle incident and
now they have to deal with this [ __ ]
as this aired yet on TV it's two minutes
long I'm just gonna swap that I don't
know what their plan is for it but
anyway eat fresh my dudes when we did
the the tier list I I stood up for
Subway and they're making me regret that
right now big time
what are you gonna try to do
he's so stoked he's like [ __ ] meatball
and this is where he kills himself
that's the river he drowned him he's
like [ __ ] that my life is complete I've
done it all
that's literally the lake he drowned in
dude look at him look at his knowing
smile like damn my life is complete I'm
[ __ ] drown myself subway do you want
me anymore monster night he's like [ __ ]
I'm gonna go [ __ ] hate this and drown
myself in this lake subway he fresh died
young he fresh died young bro it's just
a sandwich and it's not even that good
it literally ela said it best about
subway every sandwich tastes the same
like they have 30 different sandwiches
and they all tasted the same how is that
possible
do you know what I'm saying yeah I mean
it's not the best I mean I I like Subway
a little bit more than you guys it's
just why I stood up for it but I don't
know I like me yeah they're embarrassing
me now but they're somehow they make
their bread with like sawdust or
something because it's just the bread is
so weird
I made it with a shoe leather or
something like that right they actually
gotten baby powder there's like a
controversy and not leather there's like
plastic or something dude it ended up
being overblown but yeah there was there
was like a whole thing where people
freaking out about but there is
something about when you walk into a
subway like that very distinct smell
right where you feel like damn my life
is complete and I'm gonna go drown
myself
exactly yeah it tastes like all their
sandwiches taste
I mean smells like all their sandwiches
taste yeah apparently they removed the
chemical that I was talking about I just
look kind of cool was that I was called
as OD Carbone 9 that's what I like my
bread black subway eat fresh die young
apparently it's a very common ingredient
in breads nowadays but for whatever
reason oh it is yeah but people got
upset because it's also extremely common
material used in like shoe rubber I
guess interesting yeah I love how people
do that they go well Olga mats are made
of yogurt they did that to a Lacroix
they're like there's an insect in sexes
and sect aside in it and
oh yeah that's lemon juice or something
like super common yeah and still gives
me [ __ ] about that all the time I'm
drinking my Lacroix oh really and I
thought we did like a whole episode
about that man he's a little boy hater
though yeah he's a hater of many things
all right let's move it on guys there's
this girl Belle I always say Bella but I
guess her name is Belle right Belle
Delphine who is a I mean I once a porn
star I guess she's a model cam girl she
does her here let me pull up a picture
actually so funny of Dan trying to
censor all these because they're so
graphic this is the best we could do I
did the normal blur and it was just so
much like skin tone that even like fully
blurred out it was like yeah that's
still naked but yeah I see this the
swirly reminds me of that pedophile they
caught were they like Unsworth is head
you remember that the swirly just
reminds me of kiddie porn for some
reason but that works for her cuz she
does try to look as young as possible
that's kind of her thing
no she Oh she'd this girl's been wearing
braces for like 20 like ten years she
always wears braces to look as young as
possible and I was thinking I think
braces for hers like the grille version
of you know rappers wear grilles I think
that's like the grille version for
little hentai girls a little switch
Twitter ah she's got like gold-plated
braces and [ __ ] like diamond encrusted
braces sick anyway she posted on
Instagram and she said if this photo
gets 1 million she's very popular by the
way you guys probably seen her face I
actually confused her she does this oh
oh hey go what is that Dan I've never
sure how to pronounce it the crossing
your eyes and sticking out your tongue
and drooling drool let's not forget the
drawers which I guess is from it's like
a hentai thing where she's enjoying it
so much her eyes go cross-eyed drool now
I have had sex and I have no I don't
know if I'm doing it wrong but I've
never made a girl do that it's possible
I'm doing and step up the game dude bro
game but anyway she's very popular I saw
her we're doing all that cross-eyed
tongue out thing and she's very popular
girl to masturbate to on the internet I
guess as I understand it Zack you were
very taken by her weren't you no no no
no no wait why this is the first I ever
I've ever ever wait why did you bail
what do you mean you are very I mean
you're into her from from hearing about
her yeah yeah okay yeah because you were
like cuz I walked in this one I was like
how about that Bell Delfina shit's crazy
right and sacks like bro my dick is
basically my hand right now didn't you
say that I wouldn't go that far you're
you're nervous because your girlfriend
watches this and you don't want to say
too much exactly yeah
because she has a patreon with different
tiers that you can donate to yeah would
you do something like that
no probably not her page not her page so
there is someone's page you would do it
so no no no not patreon but um oh like
what like a different type of adult site
I mean oh you would but you would pay
for a premium content her specifically
yeah I mean sure have I had the money
it's the money anyway she so she she
doesn't do hardcore porn but she does a
lot of you know enough to get your here
you know but does she actually do
pornography or is it just like an
Instagram I've had trouble finding I
think she's she's super guarded about
her content so I think she sells nudes
but but not hard or anything I I don't
think she how many people at home got
their dicks out right now now I think
she does a girl [ __ ] Oh interesting I
think she's I think she gets weird and
wild but she's never like taken a dick
or anything like right right right is
that what that premium snapchats for I
think so yes so also I noticed on her
patreon dude I'm basically just doing an
ad for her [ __ ] no but I'm fascinated by
her because I've seen her floating
around so much and it's this really
strange vertical on the internet where
it's like
she's got basically like these slaves
who's on patreon and these ridiculous
tearless where people like if you donate
$100 to our on patreon she gives you her
premium snapchat and one thing that
confused me she says no screenshotting
but how does she enforce that is it show
if you screenshot does it show the
snapchat name yes Oh she'll block you
wow that's interesting because because
it is super hard to find her nudes
I was trying for researching the show
obviously late at night after you had
gone to sleep I was staying up late to
do research and it's like super hard to
find her nude so I was like how the [ __ ]
is she enforcing her her stuff so good
and I guess that's why all of her nudes
are on snapchat and she freakin bans
people that did mess it up so there's
like a whole infrastructure for doing
this these days anyway so she's popular
in Instagram and she says if this photo
gets 1 million likes I'll actually make
a pornhub account this time officially
the time has officially come tag you her
friends and dad to help out pornhub says
this is the best new news I've heard all
year and it did it got almost 2 million
likes I guess this girl's got some kind
of sense of humor I guess because she
trolled the [ __ ] out of these goddamn
sloppy virgin in cells dude people were
super sheet so she made a pornhub
account and she just rolled the [ __ ] out
of all of them and they got super angry
like a lot of her fans actually got
angry about it which cracked me the hell
up which leads me to believe that some
of these kids actually like bought
Instagram likes or something crazy to
get this going everything in this folder
is censored right then yes and we tried
our best we went all out to make this
[ __ ] sounds like do you see how much Dan
had to cut that one I just just no point
so she said you did it gamer boys I'm
still making videos for you guys
and I'll upload them in two days yeah
so here we go so here's what you posted
on on pornhub Bella delphine gets huge
dripping cream pie and it's just her
with a cream pie right yeah make making
and eating the cream pie yes Bella
delphine gets huge load balloon on earth
well what was the huge ella was shaken
up 2 litre bottle of soda that's a huge
load help Bella delphine POV doggystyle
it was a she's feeding her dog dog food
from the POV of the dog sea egg honestly
I got a tip my dick to her because she
really went all out for this and I don't
know why people are upsetting me she put
a lot of work into this gag that's
[ __ ] hilarious pewdiepie goes all the
way inside
Bella delphine well she's slowly eating
a photo of pewdiepie and then she
actually consumed the photos cue nice
smile sure yes did she say shoenice
before she consumed it don't think zona
[ __ ] low-tier [ __ ] if she said if she
said shoenice I would sign up for a
patreon right man if she got PewDiePie -
[ __ ] on on video that would be pretty
epic I break the Internet damn bell
Delfin gets her hole nice and filled up
she's eating a hamburger these titles
are [ __ ] awesome
Bella delphine plays with her [ __ ]
without didone petting a cat that one
has a million you can see all the
dislikes people are so angry man yeah
that's why I had to throw that in Belle
Delphine squirts all over the floor
forget what that was just another lie
can you imagine a della Bela de Belle
Delphine get some black in her hole
Jesus that one has the lowest fuse what
was it that what's black in the hole
did you watch that one I didn't I didn't
check that one out here I'll pull it up
hold that up with you Dan yeah but she's
in kind of revealing outfits so I can't
really show those videos safely right oh
yeah definitely not yeah no they're
definitely still not well Delphine gets
scissored
bell Delfin gets a helping hand Bell
Delfin gets double oh I did watch the
black in the whole is she's playing pool
she fell black in the hole he gets the
eight ball into the corner pocket
whatever Wow they really thought this
through
and then finally Bella delphine strokes
to big [ __ ] which was I guess she
actually and enlisted some roosters yes
it's correct well I got a tip my dick
and balls right to her for that one and
she went all out but funnily enough I
I've got these comments of all these
[ __ ] virgin idiots getting so angry
just crack me up let's see here we got
what the [ __ ] the top the top is cut but
I'm what the [ __ ] I actually was hoping
for a change in my life something to
make me feel again yet you ruined me as
a person as an individual I'm hurt by
this you scarred me for life I actually
thought you would be the better person
and drop the vids my dude yeah you
backstabbed us gamers that accept you
into our culture and society how dare
you cause play like some of our girls we
don't accept you as a Negro or a gamer
you have been shamed beyond recognition
you aren't our cistern arms anymore
sister and arms that I jerk off to
anymore just leave this place that we
all call home is he calling home pornhub
what's home Instagram in this case I
think that was an Instagram I mean bro
if you call it Instagram home yeah and
never show your face again or you will
hurt us more than you intended leave now
please or I will have to do something on
my own not to hurt you but to protect my
brothers that have been hurt due to your
actions this is just disappointing
ironic or real so a lot of these are
hard to tell at first I was thinking
they were ironic but the deeper I went
looking all these comments in good
decent amount I'll tell you I think this
one's real yeah because there's no
grammar and there's tons of misspelling
this was like a stream of consciousness
just type top rant and pure anger with
like crazy blue oh yeah we got to take a
break eh are we way over just a few
minutes over okay so we're gonna throw
it to a quick break here guys we'll be
right back with all these
upset and cell virgins at this Bell
Delphine okay we'll be right back thank
you
quip electric toothbrush is the only
toothbrush in the game that's got that
vibrating on the right price point and
the soft bristles they're gonna keep
your mouth clean as a frickin whistle
let me outline here for you okay we got
the sensitive sonic vibration it's an
effective clean that's gentle on your
sensitive gums people brush too hard in
some electric toothbrushes are too
abrasive
you got a two-minute timer belt in that
pulse aces pulsates every 30 seconds to
remind you when to switch sides and help
you clean your whole dang mouth evenly
did you know that 90% of people don't
brush for the first full two minutes and
that's how you get cavities you dip you
got a multi-use cover works as a stand
mount Stu mirror and slides over your
bristles to pack and protect your clip
on the go you got a brush head they're
automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended score of three months for
just $5 a friendly reminder when it's
time to refresh and stay committed to or
a health yeah that's right 75% of us use
old worn-out bristles that are
ineffective and by the way if you keep
your toothbrush near the toilet guess
what's on it poop particles get that out
of there get to throw that out and get
that out of there okay and introducing
kids quip they got equipped for kids if
you love quip your kids gonna love it
too it's hard enough to get kids
brushing it's good to shove that quip up
them I'll get that freaking get those
kids interested in brushing
I love quip is the only electric
toothbrush that I'll ever use for the
soft bristles and the beautiful
convenience of it in the vibrating tube
that it is that's why I love quipping
over 1 million people happy healthy
mouths do two starts at just $25 if you
go to get quipped calm /h through right
now you get your first refill refill
pack Ford Ferrari that's your first
refill pack for free at GE t qu i p.com
/h 3
if you believe that you're not being
snooped honor that nobody cares about
your online data well then I'm sorry to
disappoint you buster because you're
wrong because you listened to my show
your call here at least smart enough so
I don't know about that to understand
that your privacy is under attack
hackers governments ad companies and
ISPs are gobbling up your data like all
of it that's why I recommend getting the
software that I trust to protect my
online activity express viewed their
apps use powerful encryption to secure
your data expressvpn runs in the
background of your computer or phone and
then use the internet just like you
would normally you download the app
click to connect and voila you're
protected I never go online without
expressvpn and you shouldn't either
expressvpn is this fastest VPN I've
tried costing less than seven dollars
per month and comes in with a 30-day
money-back guarantee expressvpn uses new
cutting-edge technology called trusted
server to make sure that there's no logs
of what you do online it's time to stop
hackers Big Brother and Internet
companies and your mom from grabbing all
your data
take back your online privacy like I did
with Express VP yeah
[Music]
and protect your online activity today
and find out how you can get three
months free at expressvpn cop / h3
that's expr ESS VPN dot-com / h3 for
three months free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn dot-com / a
tree to learn more thank you Dan god
bless welcome back so as we were saying
here's another one we need to unfollow
her
we need to unfollow her all and unlike
everything we did retake the clout we
gave her and force her into making
actual porn because that's what people
have been into ever since she started
bro this guy is an actual in cell I feel
like ya put her in a clout drought and
feed it to her as a reward like the
little pet when she's actually giving us
what we wanted godly man yeah that one's
scary a clump trout a clout drought that
one's definitely real yeah Bella Belle
Delphine's gamer card has officially
been taken away and she will no longer
be accepted and our culture any longer
she has broken people's hearts and
destroyed their dignity the only apology
we'll accept as real videos and not fake
disgusting lies yeah there's a lot of
these well further down I got some
straight from pornhub and those are
pretty solid oh yeah these these ones
are definitely my disappointment is
immeasurable I am truly saddened by the
factory trolled the living [ __ ] out of
us my dick has retracted and honestly
this is the most vile thing one can do
this is the worst than the Holocaust and
9/11 you know what this is worse than
slavery you blue-balled me to an extent
that where my balls are throbbing with
pain it's like I'm getting stabbed down
there I'm going to go watch futa hint
what's food Santa is that like a little
girl [ __ ] boy
probably hentai now search that one yet
don't you know don't and now and I do
and I will not buy your premium well
there you have it folks man these guys
really like save their they were like
these guys on Instagram they're like I'm
not gonna jerk off for 48 hours
I'm waiting yeah fantastic stuff she got
him good man 1 well done Bell yeah let's
see
two days later yadda yadda yadda also
interesting to point out I think it's
worth pointing out that she follows
three people on Twitter one of them is
me so that's a pretty exclusive club so
Zach he's got the end year one separate
year one degree of separation away from
her she and Philip DeFranco is there a
commonality between these three people
they have all been on the h3 podcast
mm-hmm at various points interesting so
you think it all stems from me you're
the goat I am this girl either go I am
the focal point of her life damn the
goat PewDiePie considering she yeah had
the thing the gag with him he's clearly
more yeah he's exactly why doesn't she
follow PewDiePie he's got he's got all
the clout yeah let's put her in a cloud
trout I'm gonna put her ass in a cloud
trout I would totally bring her on the
podcast but she's in the UK God can you
imagine that would be insane I mean
she's clearly got a sense of humor I
think would be entertaining yeah I mean
this [ __ ] is hilarious and I was going
down to her the whole Belle Delphine
rabbit Hall
so here's her here's her room
and I was like god damn this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] weird I mean this girl's into
some weird [ __ ] I'll tell you for sure
she always walks around with elf ears
and look at her room bro that looks like
straight out of a true detective scene
do you know what I mean like when she
goes up the stairs being the yellow King
right like when she goes up the stairs
I'm like oh my god some children have
definitely been raped here it's like the
perfect setting for a child molestation
right Zack absolutely
some Silence of the Lambs [ __ ] at right
exactly thank you
yeah so yeah so she's she's into like
daddy Dom which I learned is uh cuz I
mean it's like where she tend to be
somebody she pretends to be a baby
essentially mm-hmm I was like I learned
that on her patreon she says she's into
daddy Dom which is where one girl
pretends to be a hopeless baby and the
other person the daddy essentially
that's just [ __ ] but I would love that
one that'd be interesting to discuss all
that because probably she doesn't want
to [ __ ] her real dad right mom would
assume would that ruin her
attractiveness to use AK if she wanted
to [ __ ] her real dad hands yeah right
because you want yeah
you're not let's just say you're not
having sex with this girl cuz she's
saying it's the crazier the better at
this point
I mean look she's got a goat head she's
got a [ __ ] bull head on her wall
amongst all this what'd I tell you this
is straight-up true detective [ __ ] Ian
would you what do you think about this
you write ice get it I get it
thank you and thank you for your
appreciate that thank you so much so
there's all these this girl is such a
phenomenon like here you can see this
one channel has 8.5 million views I
spent twenty five hundred on Belle
Delphine's patreon there's all these
different tier levels on her patreon and
every twenty five hundred yeah it's
called the Gods here where she I guess
becomes your the Dom to your daddy for a
week or some [ __ ] I don't know I'm gonna
go over to patreon rewards but like this
video has been made by so many youtubers
and they all have like 10 million views
but like I I gave her $2,500 and this is
what happened guess what nothing
happened I mean she didn't so what
I'm proposing to her oh wait before I
get into that what I'm proposing to her
is that if she here okay hang on here I
don't want sure this [ __ ] is way too
graphic [ __ ] hell
I wanted to read her tears but this
shit's way too [ __ ] graphic jeez yeah
so for 50 bucks you get the premiums
snapchat Zach mazelTov bath and shower
time selfies panty shots very
not-safe-for-work picks random naughty
video smiley face what's up haters
unique Polaroids for a hundred King you
become her King for a thousand dollars
or more which is lower than God twenty
five hundred dollars or more per month
you are my god I couldn't possibly ever
thank you enough couldn't possibly even
think of a know enough war award good
enough for this one if you achieve this
tier please private message me I'm not
sure what reward I could give you but
let's talk about it I have a feeling
that whoever gives this has something in
mind so what I was proposing to her is
that if you will make a tea reward to
call it Ethan to her above God and the
reward is I will fart in a mason jar and
mail it to you then I will become a
supporter but only feel fart in a mason
jar and sent it to me and then we'll
have Zach sniff it on air but I'm
actually I'm actually afraid this is
above the god tier how much are you
willing to pay yeah that's what I was
just hesitating it was like well hold on
[ __ ] on I don't 500 dollars for the god
tier well how okay well you you tell me
you tweet at me if you're watching this
how much it will take to get a fart in a
mason jar and sent it to us the Prophet
blessed
yeah the Papa blessed move but I want it
to be a permanent reward also other
people yeah I want other people I just
want to get I want to air the bounty I
want to make my mark on this patreon
page and she probably makes off
shitload dude there's probably at least
five neckbeards that pay her twenty five
hundred a month yeah Wow
in there alright now they're like Tim
why didn't I think about farting in a
mason jar I mean you know so Zach you
will sniff her farts right you confirmed
that to me anything for the show
thank you thank you Zach that's what I'm
talk
that's why Zach I love you I love you
here I know you're a fan of Howard Stern
like myself and those guys will do
anything for this show I mean he and I
love you I love you in but like I feel
like your dedication is just not there
on that love I sniff Skippy's loon
yeah but okay well you sniff bells fart
out of a mason jar I don't know if
there's enough fart for two people will
get two will get two mason jars
carefully I'll have her poop on five
grand right there I'll never take a
little poop in one oh let's not do that
with that would the fart work though
would it like that's a part of what I'm
interested in
well some experiment I think if she I
think if she farts in the jar and screw
the top on real fast it should preserve
this little work I do you think it will
work think it would like sustain yes
yeah I do
she lives in the UK so it would take a
minute but I think that fart would stay
would stay fresh you don't want that
[ __ ] to go stale but you has anything
for the show Thank You Zach dan do you
also I'm sure that sentiment no dad's
not there I mean would you sniff the
fart out of the mason jar you gotta come
I guess
that you see I love it love it thank you
guys
I won't make you I just wanted to know
if you would enact that's what I said
yes Zach's the one who's gonna get a big
mouthful bells yeah fart so anyway yes
this girl fascinates me man she was
probably making so much money off these
[ __ ] kids god bless her after paying
for porn yeah I've never have never paid
for porn in my entire life same
I'm guilty and I've been there since the
beginning right like day one [ __ ] hi
the first time I look at that porn I was
on a dial-up modem and I and it that
[ __ ] was like you waited for those
titties cuz it was loaded so slow line
by line I'm done by the time it loads
attack what porn did you pay for you
want me to get like specifics yeah I
mean what's good enough to pay for
brazzers brazzers is cut quality stuff
yeah but so they offer a quality that
you just couldn't find free freemium no
you gotta gotta have those 20 minute
videos you know right even though you
fast-forward through the full full the
facts interesting and Wow
yeah what does it cost for browsers
membership I think it's 20 for Holi
charity 5 a month but they got this like
incentive where they screw you because
like this was so long ago so I don't
know if it's still the same like you can
pay $1 for like a day trial they charge
your credit card that says that what you
did
yeah you're like I'm just gonna nut
today and cancel it it was on my
parent's credit card yeah it didn't go
you're like if I just spend $1 than not
real quick that's what one of my best
advice to men everywhere is just if
you're faced with a tough decision life
just like you have to jerk off but like
you have to end you know like if you
would have just like got it out before
you would have never made that terrible
decision oh absolutely I'm like you know
you regret it after oh my goodness
you're like you're possessed in that
moment you become possessed or like a
different person you're willing to do
anything and then all of a sudden once
you nut you're just like oh my god I'm
like so clear of mine right now like
what have I done not you ever get so
shamed yourself you're like this is not
who I am yeah god what is it so shameful
about pornography you just become so I
bet you everyone on this patreon page of
bells is just totally identifying with
me what have I become my only friend
did you know did you know that hurt by
Johnny or well I guess by Nine Inch
Nails was actually about paying for
pornography ya know I've heard that I
have never heard of airborne addiction
my only friend Ian have you paid for
pornography you're [ __ ] lying because
you like you're like not never I have
I'm to it I mean I I haven't either I
would I have never I have never I
frankly I've never found the need I mean
there's so much free porn it's it's
overwhelming how many options yeah it's
ridiculous and now on reddit you've got
like people they're just posting porn
like I mean people literally just like
posting porn they just give it away dude
Klout drought baby there in that Klout
route I appreciate that good for you
Zach you gotta get what you you know
what you can go look at her newest video
shilling us three videos on our YouTube
page look at this one this one called
might meet my best friend and it's her
with a dead octopus okay wait what
yes this is straight up as close as you
can get to hentai tentacle porn IRL so
here you have it a little spirited away
[Music]
the real deal folks oh my god the
thought of just [ __ ] around with the
octopus all day seriously with googly
eyes on it I mean this girl is often
twisted oh dude this is [ __ ] gross
walk I'm telling you man this girl is
[ __ ] twisted bro yeah some John water
jack are you more into it or less into
it this is pushing me away
yeah yeah it's like a run run the cue
video like this is pushing you away
because I'm sure some people are into
this because it's tentacle porn bro
she's obviously into hentai and now is
that a pancake or an egg I mean what the
[ __ ] is that it's a little rotting
carcass she's just like [ __ ] around
what this is [ __ ] is that a real
octopus
yes I'm sure it is man she is really
tapping into something for some people
though this chick is weird that's what
I'm saying she is so twisted
oh there's Mountain Dew in the fridge
god bless I wonder if that's genuine or
if that was a planted look at the
pillows all wet and [ __ ] she's putting
her head on it
oh oh they're dating kid got a sense of
humor so this shit's funny but this is
just this is a little twisted to just be
[ __ ] around with the carcass so she's
and gang clearly she's been [ __ ] with
it I wonder if they put it on ice in
between shots you know yeah I think so
but is this a desecration of life do you
think it's a little disturbing
yeah do you think she shoved that in her
vagina afterwards for a premium snapchat
only over my own sanity oh yeah I'm sure
she did well it keeps going folks and I
guess where mine is well finished it out
she's a bit of a troll I guess you would
say yeah yeah and I got to tell you guys
my dick is that like a hundred and ten
percent right holy torques huh
good I guess the joke kind of wears off
on you
yeah I didn't need to be ten minutes
long four minutes it's a long format oh
yeah this is so there you go
you know that one shocked the hell out
of me
she definitely shoved that up her badge
sorry guys do you think she's like
really into this [ __ ] or do you think
it's just like a front oh dude you seen
her bedroom bro she this is real yeah
yeah this is real as a heart attack dude
she's in the daddy Dom bro dude I
guarantee when she role plays with like
her significant others like she probably
wears a diaper and [ __ ] and they like
change her diaper and stuff yeah she
probably shits in it all the way up her
back like Theodore that's it
yeah that's all I say about Delphine
pretty much did at all
anyways shout out to her she's making
people angry she's doing it she's got a
sense of humor and she follows me on
Twitter so there you go get that cloud
girl I'm gonna put her in a cloud
drought and get some farts in a mason
jar boy cool cool so I mean I feel like
I could really add a twist to this whole
I paid Bella Delphine twenty five
hundred dollars thing because I bet you
none of these nerds got her to fart in a
mason jar duffel I think she'll do
that's anything I kind of think she'll
do wives zero doubt she'll do what did
she just [ __ ] took a bath with a dead
octopus all so she could truck you know
what she would probably just troll me in
like send a fart like you know you can
get like stink bombs she probably just
do like some I need a video for actually
farting in the mason jar enclosing it I
would approve cuz otherwise because
obviously she's not trustable she's like
a whole Timmy troll right so we need a
video of you farting in the mason jar
to prove it's real all right
let's move it on here shall we yeah man
there was some really tragic news coming
out of YouTube last week dude Nate by
the name of Atika they say that right
Edeka had a guy to go yeah not familiar
with him at all but I did happen to be
reading about his story and the anyway
the dude ended his life
he was suffering from what seemed to me
to be bipolar syndrome and having manic
episodes and going into this very
depressed episodes and unfortunately the
dude ended it man it was a crazy thing I
I don't think I've ever seen anything
like it online work he's like scheduled
a video which was essentially a suicide
letter to be uploaded after and there's
a really great write-up by dude named
Richard Lewis called how the internet
failed Etica and I think it's a really
great write-up about how this dude kept
giving out genuine cries for help and
instead of people you know reacting with
compassion it was all met with
skepticism and truly behavior and you
know people taking advantage of him and
and and people like he said he was gonna
kill himself and people were like not
believing him and so I just feel bad for
the guy man he seemed like a sweet sweet
sweet kid he actually followed me on
Twitter to which kind of when I was
doing research I was like damn I never
knew the guy you know it's kind of a
strange thing when you find out they
that he knew knew who I was
it's so hard to give people who are like
you know that fart so deep like you
could see in his video he made when he
was kind of his he it was called I'm
sorry and it was just him kind of like
but you could see how he was almost
talking like he was already dead and
it's so hard to break through to someone
who's that far along I feel like people
like the internet had already failed him
by that point you know because you could
tell him his mind he was like it's so
I'm so bad I'm so shamed I'm sorry it
has to be this way and he's talking like
from the outside for me I'm just like
dude it's not anywhere near as bad as
you think it is it's such a shame
because I've been in like the pits of
just of depression and everything feels
everything gets intensified with the
feelings of shame and guilt and
self-loathing right that's kind of a
symptom of depression that it amplifies
those feelings and so it's just not that
bad it's just not as bad as you think
you just need a little perspective and I
can close to as bad as you think you
just need a little perspective but
bipolar is a [ __ ] wicked disease
because I mean it's a it's a mental
illness really where you don't know
manic episodes where you almost become
delusional I mean the dude did like an
interview with keemstar he was
hospitalized once for being suicidal the
next day he goes on keemstar and he's
talking about how he has become a god
like clear delusions of someone who's
having a manic episode is not well and
you know
it's just people are not welcome stars
famous for saying mental illnesses fake
so don't expect much compassion from
that guy although who does but like it's
just I don't know man people need to
recognize what the [ __ ] going on like
the guy's mentally unwell I saw some of
the videos he uploaded on his channel
like shortly before he killed himself
and that dude is obviously having a
manic episode he is not well first of
all people need to understand
I wonder if keemstar changes opinion now
does he recognize mental illnesses fake
and he's got a lot of kids edgy [ __ ]
kids who have never felt bad in their
life or who I've never been to Pratt
don't know like it's so ignorant it's so
almost like it's just it's so ignorant
and [ __ ] oh so trashy and lame to be
like depressions fake or mental
illnesses fake like what the [ __ ] are
you a Scientologist
you [ __ ] break I could see myself
saying that something that dumb asked
when I was like 15 because I had never
been depressed it's like yeah I've been
sad but I got myself out of it it's like
[ __ ] you don't know what mental
illnesses like look at this poor guy
Atika you'll see what bipolar is makes
you it makes you manic it makes you
delusional when you're up and when
you're down it's almost like when you
come back to earth and then you realize
how sick you are and delusional then you
get super depressed and your feelings of
guilt and shame become amplified by a
trillion times and you want to [ __ ]
kill yourself because he said in his
video the world would be better off
without me that's like you know kind of
the best way to describe that feeling
and
people just need the [ __ ] and and
then you know after he after he kills
himself you got all these all these
people who are just so shocked by his
death keemstar is one of them who's like
man I just can't believe it a couple of
days before he's calling him a liar like
saying that he didn't believe him that
everyone was getting trolled that he
didn't kill himself I saw him tweeting
that the padlock on his apartment door
had changed he definitely didn't kill
himself
it's like bro shut the [ __ ] up man I
mean you gotta take a step back it just
anyway there's no point in talking about
yeah keemstar you get some perspective
from this
no he won't no he won't but I hope that
other people do that are more capable of
human empathy and that yeah it sucks but
anyway that I wasn't trying to talk a
lot about Etica because I don't really
know the guy don't know much of his
story I only learned about him the past
several days from the unfortunate news
but what I did want to talk about and
anyway I do wish his family and friends
and those who who knew him well and if
you are depressed it's hard to get
through to someone like that because
everyone always says and when someone
comes if you're depressed remember to
get help it's like well if your
suicidally depressed you're pushing
everyone away so it's kind of like a
circle jerk for everyone who's in
[ __ ] feeling fine
makes them feel okay about makes them
feel like they did something but it's
like too late
gotta keep an eye on your [ __ ]
friends and family do it it's easy to
tell when they're acting off it's not a
[ __ ] mystery when someone comes on
your show starts talking about their
become a god that's a red flag bro he's
not just acting wonky you know
but I would say if I had any any advice
for someone in that situation is that
it's not as bad as you think you know
you just need some perspective just wait
just wait like two days if you're
already willing to kill yourself just
wait like two days just wait it out you
know you got nothing to lose at that
point but it's not as bad as you think
poor guy he thought the world was
closing and almost like dude is not
there's nothing even wrong bro just
regroup it doesn't feel like that in his
head so that's my that's my advice to
anyone it's not as bad as you think it's
like but close to as bad as you think
you know there's not even anything wrong
you just need a little perspective a
little time but anyway we are talking
about this dude Jay Station who is a
[ __ ] douche dis guy Jay station I mean
I have choked on little Zen for Evan
little IQ j station out there Jay
station and little zan should collab
probably they could have a double-digit
IQ together Jay station does a Ouija
boards at 3 a.m. challenges it's
actually quite popular I can't imagine
why I guess with little kids but he did
I guess the same day that Etica was
announced dad sure enough your boy Jay
station makes a video called it's funny
he changed the title but it was
originally called Ouija board 3 a.m.
challenge became to end it etiquette
gone wrong you believe this [ __ ] guy
yikes it has I've never seen a like I
don't know that I've seen a like ratio
like this it has 3% likes so it's like
YouTube rewind and may I say what the
[ __ ] disguise he's got a bloody eye
what do you do what are you doing in
your life like I've never seen a trashy
er person in my life you're coming at me
with a bloody eye dog are you even gonna
acknowledge that your eyes bloody like
what the [ __ ] is wrong
dear God look at this trash asylum I
checked Twitter right now
and I saw the most horrific news I've
ever seen man honestly guys and it comes
from comments on my youtube channel
telling me - you better not do the Ouija
board it's funny that he drew a line
here I mean he did title it would you
board 3m challenge to be Connecticut
gone wrong so I didn't even know why he
went there he heard you already [ __ ]
did the clickbait but he so he did this
guy's famous for doing this Mac Miller
died the next day did Mac Miller will he
do bored xxx tanishi 'im how do you say
that yin fantasy only believed in Tassie
on he did a Ouija board challenge with
10th asean apparently they're like and
through the Ouija board they're urging
people to buy his merch do their ghosts
which is pretty dull that seems very
good meaning for him very real they're
like yo it's me [ __ ] Mac Miller from
the grave you should hope you should buy
Jay station's merch [ __ ] epic yeah
watch this idiot with his bloody eye you
know what man I see a lot of these
youtubers tweeting about Etica oh you're
my best friend of this guy's the
greatest I see people making YouTube
videos about it bro your title of your
video is Ouija board 3m challenge
speaking Attica got him wrong why did
you even make this video he's like in
his car so he clearly was like oh [ __ ] I
gotta get on this quick he didn't even
have time to get home and record dude
even that still has a seatbelt on for
Christ's sake do you have time to take a
seatbelt off he literally was driving
and he's like oh [ __ ] pulled over
seatbelt still on 3m challenge baby
let's go
what's this shirt say bust or die
plastered that's that's the the slogan
of Bell Delphine's fanbase that's right
busted die [ __ ]
they not doing [ __ ] bro
so what your YouTube video don't have
ads bro donate to that [ __ ] this was
monetized by the way to edit callers
family or mental health when you're
tweeting about it are you making a
youtube video about it you doing it for
attention bro shut the [ __ ] up
this guy [ __ ] to all and he's got a
bloody eye
this guy's like Maury level of human
trash if I saw this guy in Moore doing a
DNA test I wouldn't be surprised in the
least bit this guy would be an episode
of Maury we're like three girls come out
and each one's fatter than the next one
and then one dude comes out like one
trans dude comes out and he's like I
didn't know you were a man oh he like
picks the trans girl he's like I'm in
love with the I'm in love with Sammi
he's like actually my name my real name
is Samuel whoa those are the best apps
aren't they you guys watch Maury [ __ ]
you no no not a big Maury fan I'm afraid
the paternity test
yeah returnee test that's like a
stranger paternity yeah yeah J station
you are the father this guy's so trashy
he would dance on stage J station you
are not the father he starts breaking
out in a breakdance
his eyes all bloody and [ __ ] girls
crying
you don't really care though you're just
doing it for attention bro lucky man are
you I almost died like a week ago bro
this video is so strange he's not even
talking about Etica he's like he click
baited the worst thing and he's calling
out other youtubers like you're not even
talking about the dude who died or Mets
out there anything what is this video
Doug
for real breath breath my car right now
I'm ready to die bro I feel like I'm
gonna get murdered bro what you know
what that feels like
I think you what oh he's in ready to get
murdered in his car maybe you shouldn't
have stopped in such a hurry if you're
in that rough of a neighborhood also
where do you live also what are you do
in your life what IVA bloody I also why
so paranoid what drugs are you on dog
does meth make you paranoid uh yeah if
you do it do it if you do it enough
don't sure enough yeah I think this guy
smoking math does meth make your I
bloody no but it makes you it can make
you do things that will get you bloody
yeah yeah for sure this guy some I
thought he had pinkeye at first but the
I realized that I think he just has a
black eye yeah well I'll tell you won't
be surprised if this guy had pinkeye but
I'm that's too intense yeah no I think
you're right that guy got got be punched
in the [ __ ] I guess that's probably what
he's talking about maybe maybe he got
jumped recently that's what I'm saying
you almost died yeah I'm sure you had
nothing to do with the instigation of
that yeah can we talk about etiqa please
know that [ __ ] is fake my dude oh he
faked the video about him almost dying I
forgot so this guy uploaded a video
recently is that what the black eyes
from hello - yeah I'm starting to think
that these things are connected here I'm
sorry for look at the thumbnail do you
see this it's his face with the Ouija
board and of arrow at it bro you are
such ass so where was the one where he
got beat up Oh home invasion I almost
died last night here he probably got his
ass beat and then was just tried to make
up a story about what's poppin guys oh
yeah he's probably wondering what is
going on with me because my face my face
yeah yeah oh god you guys like it you
like my eye and look scary looks really
scary yeah but guys right now what I
just wanna let you know
really safe safe want to talk for a
really nice place good golf course
good okay it's looking nice it's a lot
better than the hell that I used to call
home because I'm gonna have to get a new
house I'm gonna have to move I'm gonna
keep this all Ron uncut mainly because
it's like 6:00 6:30 at night and I
haven't slept since yesterday
look it's a man this guy's hard to make
up yo so uh oh god my eye looks like a
zombie look at my head y'all actually
[ __ ] up my son yeah I mean unless on
their cell phone of me get of me all
[ __ ] up anyway this guy's just come
back he takes everything so I'm not
surprised sure he definitely got his ass
beat by someone right like that's not
makeup
it doesn't look fake yeah yeah my guess
is he got his ass beat and then he made
up his horse what are these guys
thinking you guys whoever robbed me are
the stupidest [ __ ] I've ever
seen and I know median life and if I
ever got one of those knives out of your
hand
mmm I would have stabbed you silly bro
hmm there's a wholesome contour I like
that yeah I like that retrospective talk
man if I would have got that knife out
of your hand I would have stabbed the
[ __ ] out of you I'm back to my house and
guys let me let me tell you this they
said to me they yelled on me on the
floor when I was chained up they say you
called the police we're gonna come back
here and kill you I went straight to the
[ __ ] police breath what a better
[ __ ] man Wow
go ahead and do it myself I'll be in
jail I read the comments cuz everyone
saying it's fake here let's see I was
beating a robbed
uh
[Music]
Edda cos coast traveled through time and
beat his ass that's fine I hope your
next video is titled being alive gone
wrong if it's real let's see a copy of
the police report
there you have it be pretty easy to
prove that me on your ass like [ __ ]
also if you just had a home invasion got
beat up and you're threatening to kill
the people that did it to you
don't don't show outside your window
like he was showing so much I think he's
in a hotel room but I actually feel like
I know where he is but I guess I won't
say it for well yeah apparently he lives
in Canada so probably I mean who the
[ __ ] knows but anyway this guy's a total
piece of [ __ ] look at this thumbnail I
didn't actually never even saw this
thumbnail I'm enjoying this one with him
trying to take a higher I'm depressed
I'm breaking down I got depression or I
do something bad it's because I was
depressed he's hard on that [ __ ] cuz you
know what is true bro these youtubers
are doing this making five different
videos about being depressed
brob sad too bruh but I'm not about to
say I got depression dude cuz you know
wait yikes this guy just killed himself
what are we what are we doubting
depression in the video rep Etica human
being real man this guy I said he
reminds me so much of fouseytube it's
crazy so here's the one he made about
Mac Miller after shortly after he died
got that Gucci had on you know a rep
bird by now Mac Miller unfortunately
passed away two days she was one day
throw at least give his spear some time
to ascend to heaven man
how's it gonna talk Ouija board with you
already man he's on his way up
I immediately think about the days I
went to high school in and today he
passed away at age 26
well anyway guys let's get the Ouija
board out communicating with Mac Miller
audio speaker bluetooth so he's got
across to Jesus
it's got frosted Jesus a picture Mac
Miller and some dollar-store candles
these are literally dollar store candles
with pictures of like the mother Mary on
it so easy to this is it bro it's just a
lot of this man and then the TV yeah
this car is honestly the biggest [ __ ]
leech piece of [ __ ] ever and here's the
one of ten hmm
correct me if I'm wrong I don't know
stage name xxx tent I see own tent s um
thank you again this one has a lot of
use ant a Co
[Music]
what are you guys doing cut to the chase
he shows off his new house and then they
go to the basement and Ouija board I'm
pretty sure if we contact him we don't
have anything to worry about
I've never actually played around with
one of these it's pretty scary it's my
first time I'm nervous about it honestly
all of us have to put our hands on the
Ouija board and we're guys like
seriously that was late we're gonna try
this one more time I'm gonna try to
contact something up of the planchette
now
it's not even my work are you sure this
work it always works like go move your
hands that's how it works you've done
this before I've done it many times it
always works and it's not doing anything
now what did we do you were moving your
hand this time dum-dum what do you do
normally you just asked to communicate
yes and you just go from there
especially at 3 o'clock in the morning
it helps if you have a picture of
whatever spirit you're trying to contact
okay here we go that's gonna move for
sure is there any spirits that wish to
communicate with us they pulled up his
picture on a cell phone man like how
ghetto does it get you see this peanut
from Jeff Dunham's I can literally see
your finger moving I mean this has two
and half million views
I just this [ __ ] is beyond the pale man
and his message is basically to buy his
merch introducing Lee do a challenge
where you go back in time and give your
dad a condom yeah so there you have a J
station some quality stuff right there
yes it's it's interesting how this guy
got on one hand preach about youtubers
using the tragedy in a video without a
Ouija board 3m challenge speaking with
Etica gone wrong and which he pulled
hastily to the side of the road with the
seatbelt still on and made a video damn
anyway take some balls give him that
yeah the whole thing was such a tragedy
you know looking back at his videos this
guy etiquette he seemed like a sweet kid
you know he seemed like a [ __ ] sweet
kid
but I'm glad that J station was able to
contact him and get some closure on this
because there's a lot of pain and in
people's hearts and I'm just glad that
Chase station is out there fighting the
good fight with his Ouija board
you know yep we got to get J station a
show on like lifetime the Ouija board
challenge we'll call it I think it is
more of like a TLC you guy TLC yeah we
call it the Ouija board gala which is
the one that has all the ghost hunters
and [ __ ] yeah I think the TLC Travel
Channel yeah travel yeah
yeah it's called the traveling to heaven
Channel shows J station on Travel
Channel we do bar challenge we'll call
it gone wrong and each episode he'll
contact a recently deceased a celebrity
to see what what merch they're gonna
plug this week that idea has legs I'm
telling you it's got legs right no
there's someone that died recently Paul
Newman this is Jay station which of your
salad dressings is your favorite Paul
Newman likes his ranch dressing of the
fest so Bill de Blasio's the mayor of
New York and he is running for president
on the Democratic ticket along with
everyone else in America I think there's
about 350 million people running on the
Democratic ticket bill de blasio I like
to call him and this [ __ ] just cracked
me the [ __ ] up he goes lucky to have the
talented debater Dante de blah de blah
CEO helping me get ready for Wednesday
and he shares text messages with his son
that made me want to actually die dude
like what the [ __ ] this is just so
cringy man
listen to this [ __ ] Dante the debates
coming up I'm preparing intensely but I
must admit I'm a little nervous what
advice do you have for me thanks love
you dad I mean what is this like a
[ __ ] call him for advice hey Dad I'm
glad you've asked I've got a few ideas
first of all you're going to want to
establish credibility especially among
skeptical young voters tell the story of
how you met mom while working as a young
staffer at City Hall she was only 15 in
you were 30 most people said that yeah
that you were too old for her but not
but you told her that love is just a
number and in the words of our Kelly you
said do you have your passports do you
have your papers no what he said is tell
the story of how you met mom while
working as a young staffer at City Hall
and weave into it a reflection about how
hard it is to find like the one on
tinder oh my god he did actually say
that he did make it Twitter reference
tinder what I say Twitter yeah yeah
Longtin okay but I'm looking for maybe a
little more universal message she's like
son you're a [ __ ] idiot what else you
got ah okay well in a time of
unprecedented national division one
thing we can all agree on our dogs sorry
what you're going to want to build your
platform and debate around dogs bring
photos better yet higher higher a litter
of puppies to the debate stage have them
oh he's making actually a joke it'll be
adorbs
that's definitely a creative approach
but how about something that allows me
to stand out by talking about my
accomplishments I need to impress the
American people by showing them I'm a
can-do guy oh okay in that case tell the
people that New York City was just
Staten Island when you started your
first term
hmm he's roasted why don't we focus on
technique instead you are a champion
debater tell me how can really make my
presence felt on that stage okay I hear
you this one's a sure thing
donk I'm thinking you enter the stage at
a jog into a Zion leap over the monitor
okay yeah this so isn't it's not the
most embarrassing thing ever I'm
thinking enter the stage at a jog and do
his eye only over the moderator to the
rim total power move repeatedly it would
be great if you could clarify some of
these NBA trade rumors because I for one
am confused well that certainly would
get attention let me think about it
of course just make sure you don't
overthink it
make sure your message is
straightforward talk with your
accomplishments and treat your opponents
with respect you'll do great
thanks coach love you know price [ __ ]
you your son hates your app I can assure
your son 8zu if you actually message
your son hey Dante this debates coming
up people like [ __ ] you dad I told you
never to contact me Dante can you
imagine [ __ ] posting I wonder if even
asked his son's the top comment Jesus
Christ it has some dignity which is just
so true bill de blasio was he mayor when
you lived out there I have no idea these
texts are crazier than Anthony's Wiener
at least says were genuine yeah I mean
these are totally made-up right yeah I
mean this is not his son this is not a
real conversation effort what does Dante
actually think about this Dante is like
bro if you would have asked me I would
have said don't post that [ __ ] [ __ ] bill
de blasio man I don't care what this guy
qualifications are I'm not voting for
him as just by this text alone by this
tweet alone from what I mean I'm not
from out there obviously but from what I
understand he's pretty [ __ ] unpopular
in New York so like his own City doesn't
even like himself love his name though
working out too far his name amazing
bill de blasio yeah bill smoked the
build ablaze Blasio
I got to do this with Theodore someday
actually you know be great when he's
one-year-old I'll have him be like look
at this conversation I would Theodore
and he's that well dad I'm glad you've
asked I've got a few ideas he has
cracked me out
I watched the debates last night I hate
watching those debates I'll be honest
it's rough everybody says the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's just dirt I just feel
like there's no I'll tell you I Trump
won because he was at least like it's so
mind on me everybody saying the same
[ __ ] thing dude there's no nobody
stands out to me everyone's like oh this
person one this person one I'm like dude
they all say the same [ __ ] but what can
you do it's all I mean well how do you
stand out it's like putting kids in
cages is wrong we all need health care
we all the top the top 1% owns 50% of
the nation's wealth I've been hearing
the same talking boats for like my whole
[ __ ] life I still watch it though you
guys watch it yeah watch it watch Bowl
tonight's thoughts I watch them both too
I mean you got to stand out who do you
like well I mean the stand out from last
night I think was obviously Paris mm-hmm
especially considering she had like zero
[ __ ] momentum before last night so you
know she had the most to gain and not
very much to lose I think she was
pulling it like 3% before last was she
really yes she was way down there single
digits for sure lo single did I like her
man she's sharp she's fiery yeah well I
mean I I'm not a supporter of her
politics but I will admit she she she
did extremely well in the debate you
know I would disagree with what you said
about nobody stand out I feel like she
did wait what what do you disagree about
her politics I'm just curious uh I mean
she's I guess not her politics as much
as her background you know she was a DA
here in California and did a lot of
questionable things I don't know if you
heard about the whole truancy thing do
you remember that no actually kicked in
when we well you're a little older than
me but when we're in high school they
implement a new rule that if if a kid
was truant from school the parent could
get arrested and that was heard of yeah
she pushed for that hard whoa yeah I
wonder what's going on in like the inner
city you know that but but I mean still
that seems like really yes Elliot
policies in the past well you know she
the stuff she's campaigning on now is is
different than that but yeah I don't
know interesting but better look into
that but I mean yeah I'm not a big Biden
fan and she [ __ ] oh my in such a tool
he's such a actually you know what I
feel bad saying anything bad about the
guy because that dude has the most
tragic background of all time his wife
and daughter died in a car crash and
then his son got brain cancer and died
like bro [ __ ] you get you get to be
President just on paid America that's so
bad I just oh my heart melted when I
yeah I mean that is rough and it is
rough but how you come back you know the
worst sob story is not necessarily the
best metric to pick a president well
sure Dan if you want to be technical
about it
but I don't like him he's just a stiff
he's too [ __ ] old
I want someone young you know the little
life low fire yeah I like the young
dudes and I'm a Bernie Sanders guy I was
all about him laughing during the last
cycle but he's too I'm sorry
I just think he's too [ __ ] old yeah I
like I'm a Bernie guy too but I gotta
say I did not think he did well last
night at all I was not well I think I
mean look performance look everyone
always says that there in debates look
that's like the word
let me speak directly to them okay
people right yeah look look but no I did
not like um
Phil I do not like and I just want
someone who sharp who's young who can
still think you know listen
how old is Bernie like 75 no offence so
old people out there but I've met a lot
of [ __ ] broke if you
eight year old person I mean some of
them are sharper and they're still there
but they're not as [ __ ] sharp as they
were when they were goddamn 40 or 50
mm-hmm you know yeah and four years is a
long time when you're 80 goddamn years
old right yeah yeah no I'm with you I'm
with you I'd love to you know Trump is
pretty old to that [ __ ] just
like covers it up a spray-tanning like
hey hey hey he looks like his hey on his
hair but anyway he's looking a lot older
these days I gotta tell you I mean that
it always happens yeah when you're
president you know you age real quickly
but yeah he's a man burning I think are
the same age or maybe weird that that
blows my [ __ ] mind that they're the
same age Trump
age because man will burn evidence he
was like 30 have you 73 Bernie 77 I mean
yeah by the time bernie takes office
he'll be like 78 and a half yeah by the
time he finishes will be 82 and if he
does two terms which most presidents
aspire to most presidents do do two
terms maybe going they'll be 68 dude no
not 60 how did you come up with that
number 66 or 86 I'm in a t-888 yeah
going on 90 [ __ ] - yeah you better
have a great VP mm right you know honor
that uh well I hope I guess all I'll say
is I hope by the time the next debate
rolls around we've we've thinned the
herd a little bit because this [ __ ]
30 candidate thing is stupid as hell
yeah there's so many people up there
there was like why the [ __ ] are you
there there was a lot I call mystic oh I
love her it just an author and
Williamson it just an author and she
starts talking about like holistic
healing the country and I was like the
dude I've got I've got a strange
connection to her I gotta say she's
she's part of this she's part of the
broad so crowd no don't you [ __ ] tell
her she's a broad so I'm not kidding she
tell me the the company that used to
work for that did all that [ __ ] for
broad so that weird connection I have to
that huh they did her events too
so she's in a brothel she probably
gays right before though she does like
spiritual guru [ __ ] she get on stage
she's got a decent amount of support
she's Oprah's spiritual advisor no yeah
the more I learn about Oprah the crazy
thing is I mean she's kooky for sure but
some of her she actually came out with
some pretty fire answers a couple times
that's like damn the [ __ ] exact but
what she's like I remember that my
favorite answer was when she said what
we need to do is replace the house of
Congress every seat we need to put a
healing crystal in the seat instead of a
person and we need to come to the center
of the room and we need to have a a
crystal shower where all the house
representatives lay on the ground and we
play vibrating musics that vibrate with
the crystals and you get rings be a
hundred line 434 Hertz tuning exactly
one hurt off or one hurt above or below
and the country will will have a World
War three I think I've I'll feel bad if
I'm wrong about this so take it with a
grain of salt but I think I've heard
that she's anti-vaxxer so um yeah she's
she's got some that doesn't surprise me
during the crystal healing you're
definitely back by the way Bernie
Sanders is six feet tall I'm seeing here
that's pretty impressive six feet yeah I
mean he looks like a you know Trump is
apparently quite tall as well you say
yeah he's like he's a large it's a large
man Lauren had asked him he's got it
don't got a [ __ ] fat ass got a big
old dumper that guy damn I like to get a
piece of that ass like that [ __ ] Big
Mac ass
speaking of cringy politics Justin
Trudeau was asked how he's helping to
reduce plastic this is the Prime
Minister of Canada
always being reducing plastic waste in
his personal life and this guy was not
ready for this question man you and your
family do to cut back on plastics we we
have recently switched to drinking
water bottles out of water out of when
we have water bottles out of a plastic
sorry away from plastic towards paper
backs water bottles sort of things
there's there's a number utiful I love
that alright can you repeat that what
are you doing again mr. Prime Minister
water out of when we have water bottles
out of a plastic away from plastic
towards paper like drink box water
bottles sort of things there's there's a
number king king what a ledge so he was
really promoting box water is better it
seems like he's like you know what I'm
doing for the internet [ __ ] excuse me I
drink water out of up out of a paper
carton okay what the [ __ ] are you doing
for the environment [ __ ] next question
inbox water is better over that box
water [ __ ] you made a video about that
yeah you did damn you're you're a
[ __ ] real fan Dan I've been watching
since uh [ __ ] uh-huh 2014 something
that's pretty cool black box waters a
deep cut from Ethan and Eva yeah so I
gotta ask you how is knowing me changed
your perspective on my count off way
down way down no I mean your real dude
you're pretty much what what you do in
fact you see you guys you what you see
is what you get people and it's not just
cuz I'm paying him you see I'm a genuine
[ __ ] guy you know the other hand
hates me yeah right hand only when you
go in on the Kim K well yeah what boy I
actually have a Kim K segment here I
don't know how you keep defending her in
because she's so obnoxious
well you defended her Ethan hold on
today you stuck up for Kim a couple
times me yeah haven't you it's not all
negative so I don't know I'm pretty
consistent with my Kim K hate you know
alright fair enough I was trying to say
I was trying to save your clout you're
gonna go
no no minor clout drought a star dude
well what I always say about Kim K is
like we all used to universally agree
that she was a sucky human being and
somehow she got cool by like marrying
Kanye once she's woke now you know she's
getting people out of prison and stuff
it's okay that's an honorable thing I
agree suppose I totally agree actually
you know what I will say to her credit
you're absolutely right she met with
President Trump and she got some like
one of these wrongly convicted people
out of prison people yeah pretty pretty
amazing I haven't done that I just like
raised like $10,000 for Bella Delfy and
I'm gonna fart in a mason jar today like
I didn't do [ __ ] for anybody Bella
Delphine man I think it's just Bell Bell
sorry I keep saying Bella - I don't know
it's just I think it's ed yeah it's in
rate her on one to ten and don't [ __ ]
lie to me just please for once be honest
with me right here on the scale of one
to ten I'm talking Beller yeah Bell okay
we already did Kim yeah actually I think
she even got some [ __ ] for that - he
said she's seven and he got a lot of
blowback I won't make you talk about cam
again but tell me I'm on a scale of one
to ten pal come on speak frankly with me
hmm
think about it Thank You doc give me
some time give me about a couple hours
and I'll get back to you a couple hours
back - he's so unhelpful to me he's got
a follow your advice and clear his mind
if you know what I mean before he may go
jerk off will you answer here's I think
she's pretty attractive I gotta say
though the the pictures of her with the
braces on that's like that's instant
turnoff for me I'm gonna say with or
without the braces ya know though it
without the braces you know she's she's
objectively beautiful girl but the
braces is just that's too creepy for me
and what so she would you do a daddy Dom
roleplay with her like a diaper and [ __ ]
now
sorry now you would name I think now no
she's hard to change my dog off yeah
mommy can I be the baby I'm baby man
I've changed enough diaper these last
week's I want someone to change my
[ __ ] dive exact I'm not gonna lie
when I'm changing Theodore's diaper I'm
like dude I'm not gonna I'm gonna be
honest with myself this is pretty dumb
they just piss and shits wherever you
live oh it's go kind of dope yeah like
I'm ready to start wearing a diaper in
my life I need a daddy Dom nothing
stopping you man
nothing's hotter than a big-ass load of
[ __ ] and diaper nothing ain't nothing
like that steamy and the words of Brent
okay what the [ __ ] we talking about so
steamy so steamy Kim Kardashian speaking
of uh Ian did you like Kim K before she
married Kanye I did like like I never
had anything against her though okay
she came okay you know I'm not gonna
force you here I just liked her I
thought whole Kardashian thing right
this is [ __ ] right and every time she
comes in to the public eye it's like
another eye rolling thing like here's
our new shapewear it's called called
kimono which apparently a lot of people
are upset about the cultural appropriate
cultural appropriation because the
kimono is a Japanese dress I actually
don't care about that as much I just
think that didn't we as a civilization
go beyond corsets like she's selling
corsets dude well here I got more
pictures but anyway this person is all
upset she says one is a kimono one is
Kim shamelessly selling a line of
shapewear which you don't need I love
that I love that which y'all don't need
which I agree with [ __ ] this [ __ ]
yeah it's stupid I mean the whole
cultural appropriation thing that
doesn't bother them usually but I'm not
always so ma'am look at this [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] is wrong with you doesn't she
look like Grandma undies man sucking
that fat boy I probably look good with
those I'll lose 30 pounds immediately we
should get we should get you a pair try
oh my goodness that's a great idea yeah
we should do that you know it's the best
way to boycott Kim Kardashian by Jake no
that's a funny idea I do want that Dan
get on that or I'll buy you a commune I
want to shape up baby I'm probably gonna
be like the biggest size they have pick
up till like three are like 6 XL yeah
she's very inclusive when it comes to
her products so good on her yeah she
knows a lot of she knows who she knows
who she's making that for let's be
honest not me because Kim is almost like
fat and skinny at the same time because
like her what her hips are like why
didn't her bust is crate like unnatural
so she's probably like you know the
cultural appropriation thing like I said
it's kind of an eye roll in most cases
anyways but this one isn't this like
really a stretch she's not making
kimonos yeah the name of the company no
I agree that doesn't bother me you know
I would sort of understand if she was
making traditional Japanese kimonos or
something but well I hate everything
culture appropriation I think is stupid
but apparently so let me go on because
apparently she trademarked kimono which
people did not like oh the word come on
yes she trademarked kimono
but again I think that's a
misunderstanding because I've been
through the trademark and all this with
you know Teddy fresh and our garments
and she correctly points out that kimono
is being just trademarked for her for
other I'm what do you call it out fat
make you skinny wear spanks spanks is
one of those shapewear shapewear you go
yeah that's a that's a good euphemism
for [ __ ] make your fat ass look
skinny it's corset like you said
yeah
but yeah the fact that she trademarked
it is just in regards to that other
shapewear companies can't name the [ __ ]
kimono that's how a trade marks work
right now
so there could be another kimono it's
just yeah it's you're making likely
unrelated you're making plates called
kimono yeah right
so I'm related yeah yeah it's definitely
a stretch to get mad at her over this
but there was a lot of more didn't I put
and all these other pictures but she
said of this finally I can share with
you guys this project that I've been
developing for the last year shut the
[ __ ] up you didn't work on the show all
right in I've been passionate about this
for 15 years I've been passionate about
this before I had fake tits and ass and
I knew one day that my body would be so
disfigured I would need to shape it up
with a corset kimono is my take on
shapewear and solution for women that
actually work I developed this style for
all those I wanted to wear for all those
times I wanted to wear his dress or
skirt with the slit and still needed the
support what wait what does that mean I
developed this style for all those times
I wanted to wear a dress or skirt with a
slit it still needed the support cuz I
think normally these the the Spanx type
things or shapewear or whatever comes
all the way down your leg and hers is
design
you know right so it's pretty niche I
developed this style for all those times
I wanted to wear a dress or so it's the
same line twice
introducing kimono solution where Tien
baby for everybody even Ethan from sizes
xx s to 4 XL baby can't wait for you to
feel this fabric can't wait for your
intestines to be sucked up into your
liver
oh but also to play on our name Kim Ono
which is the cornea [ __ ] I just want to
[ __ ] kill myself Kim oh no come on
we're here where's this article that had
a bunch of pictures of it maybe it's
here
so but let's get me some kimonos cuz I
think I will look good I wonder what
they're trying to see if they're for
sale yet
Kim's must-haves looks like she's not
selling it yet yeah it said it's coming
soon okay
I'll get us going but I on that will
definitely get you hooked up I can't
find these pictures what the f what are
you trying to find there's a bunch of
pictures of all the kimono shits and I
just saw like now whatever of her
products yeah on her product
it's just when you it's the Instagram
link you just flip through pictures oh
maybe I didn't scroll yeah yeah I didn't
scroll so here you go
did what is going on here may I ask what
kind of [ __ ] like secret society it
is it's a little look at her ass this
lady's ass is like you can't look me in
a transparent yes it's too tight Kim
what is wrong with you look at these
people going around her like she's like
a goddamn maypole all hail day the Queen
well who knows you're knocking it now
but once you try it I mean and you see
your improved figure it looks like the
most uncomfortable thing ever
why lose weight when you can buy Kim's
kimono your fat ass can lose 30 pounds
immediately it may cause irreparable
harm to your ribs and internal organs
but you look great by Kay mono today
yeah I don't know how these work is it's
just super tight to the extent that it
just kind of yes squeezes you in it
shapes your body gives you a curve baby
does sound pretty on curves in a good
way your does your fat ass need help
shaping your disgusting formless body
well you can head on over to kimono comm
where we sell girdles to suck your
disgusting diabetic fat ass in to make
it look like you're 30 pounds lighter
you may experience trouble breathing and
kidney failure
but you look great Kimmo no I'm your PM
Kim oh no do you want to squeeze the
[ __ ] out of your intestines and [ __ ] in
your pants Kim oh no it's too tight this
[ __ ] can't escape your butthole yeah
wait a minute thinking about it what do
you do if you have to go to the bathroom
probably slide it down there's like a
pretty big inconvenience this body suit
looks [ __ ] gnarly dude
Mandy's girl like praying there they
like worship her
we're in the the skin suits from
Evangelion I'm into that show makes me
uncomfortable at times I don't know why
they're like why do they have to have so
much like 14 year old like sex in it
yeah
Kim's a [ __ ] weirdo sorry and look at
this freak it's [ __ ] freak body easy
sorry freak ass tits fake tits that look
like [ __ ] the Frankenstein's monster
put them together her tits are crazy
dude
all right I should stop I can feel us
scowling I don't like her everything's
fake about her she's just making
everyone feel bad and this is this is a
this is a continuation of it like
shapewear like all the products are like
how do you transform your body and feel
and how to had it you need things you
need to buy my stuff to feel normal you
know you know it's all about that and by
the way her freakish body is gonna look
good in that corset but your fat ass
isn't if you go get plastic surgery and
get a fake everything yeah maybe if you
won't you won't need this
I've heard that these things work I mean
I I don't actually know personally but
mm-hmm
I mean it's a big industry it it's got
to do something right is it really I
didn't know people walked around with
this [ __ ] yeah I think so Hockney I know
about the Spang
that that Zach brought up that's like
the the classic one that's been around
for a while I don't know I don't like
there I don't we're gonna find out man I
don't like anything she does I don't
like what you sell I don't like what she
does I'm like her message you know
anyway sorry I'm sorry Paul apologies
for that one D in OJ Simpson on Twitter
who can I can't stop watching OJ Simpson
on Twitter man this guy it's like he's
been through so much in his life you
know got away with murder he served
eight years in prison and now it's all
come down to this Oh Jay Simpson on
Twitter baby
rest in peace of Michael there's a lot
going on in this video he talks about I
don't know he talks like he's in an
infomercial hey guys it's it's yours
truly here nice audio disc
[Laughter]
what is he angling it he's trying to get
a show or some [ __ ]
I think oj deserves a top reality show
or talk to you know I would totally
watch that we will be called killing it
with OJ yeah I would totally watch that
hey Twitter world he starts with that
hate Twitter world I love that [ __ ] and
not seem around usually I was playing
tennis in my backyard with a neighbor
when he got
that is nappy Wilson home from the
summer camp because they found out he
had cancer and I guess it had something
to do any surance and he called some of
his friends he was a celebrity you
called some of his friends I called
Michael he was real hot there to see it
even though we got together to help but
did you really bring a framed picture of
golfing do you know what I'm saying like
you just pulled that up like yep yeah I
just card around with this photo how is
this dude golfing all the time I didn't
always close money because he got sued
into oblivion but apparently he moved to
Florida which is some kind of they have
some kind of law about state law that
makes it hard for people to get money
from you he still has his NFL pension
they could not touch that Oh for real is
that big yeah yeah they really courts
cannot touch that you have any idea how
much he gets from that I can tell you
but I know he has his pensions though OJ
Simpson net worth his net worth is
somewhere between a quarter of a million
dollars that's a lot of no I'm laughing
but two three million dollars
I mean I'm laughing I guess because this
guy used to probably be worth like
apparently his pension is about four
grand a month from then I felt that is
not a lot that is not golfing money no
he's definitely angling it's something
Twitter world yep but he's the juice
he's got to have money stocks away
somewhere right well if he does I mean
the government's gonna come for it right
but anyway I think Florida's some kind
of Haven so he seems like he's doing
well he's out to sushi in one video he's
golfing in one video he's living it up
man hey Twitter world it's yours for the
world is truly sorry did you lost the
title of yours truly when you murder two
people
hey that's right okay we we got a we got
to issue a an update from from last week
did you hear about this what
well the some somebody emailed me
calling into question the
the the DMS that we talked about last
really yeah
what was the mean so a lot of people
think that in that guy's videos the real
oj that the l in real is actually a
capital i that's how he kind of but
didn't he click it and go to his profile
did but he might have done a little
slickness to do it he didn't seem that
slick to do it in the video yeah I know
um I I'm still questioning it I feel
like I feel like that's a valid point to
bring up but the the proof that it was
fake I didn't really think was
definitive but I think we need should
acknowledge it's quite possibly fake but
he clicked the I feel like the click
would be hard to if you remember in that
video though he's pretty clumsy when
he's clicking he's like why isn't this
working it like takes a second so it I
could see I've definitely I'm definitely
skeptical now I don't know I don't know
for sure one way or another but but we
should acknowledge he may not have
threatened to kill somebody it's 50/50
I'm gonna say 50 there you go I mean
they do did murder people so right we're
not surprised he's threatening people
and the DMZ so I guess kids with cancer
now I know they're probably many similar
gaps like that appreciate your donation
and I've been scared as [ __ ] to hang out
with OJ you're like dude I know you
murder two people with a knife like I'd
be scared of that [ __ ] like you
play golf with him you know and you're
out in the you know it was just the two
of you just the two of you and all the
sudden he's like he was your ball there
was your ball really there you know yeah
like [ __ ] Oh Jay maybe it wasn't here
you know I don't wanna make you angry
and the guy I mean he'd to performed an
armed robbery in Las Vegas to they went
to jail for eight years for so [ __ ] I
wouldn't hang out with this [ __ ]
yeah he's a little scary driving on a
white golf cart that's a little too
risky for me
I would totally jump out and roll out of
that golf cart just like a tuck and roll
and Vic [ __ ] Pisa LJ he's probably a
nice guy
tink so yeah yeah until you don't cross
him them [ __ ] crossing I mean man to
murder someone two people with a knife
that's just too gnarly that's intense
man yeah with an intimate way to do it
too gnarly
years later my house was on the sea dope
get a utility belt with a knife in it
they just cruise around list I wonder if
that's illegal
I probably if you just have like a
kitchen like a butcher knife and utility
belt IV [ __ ] epic just a utility belt
with like around his waist
yeah the point is he was nice to me so
he definitely didn't rape kids
peace out I love that bro okay out come
on
that is the best [ __ ] ever didn't even
crack a smile you like pizza
he's like anyway peace out Michael
recipes I'm out drive away so epic
everything he does is like from a 90s
you know talk show yeah his soul rest in
peace Michael
take care I got some golf to play see
you so sick
so anyway people started naming his how
we pulled out at the end there
rightfully so I mean come on how do you
not hear I pull up some of my favorites
just in the Twitter comments here we go
take care take care very good obviously
very very nice and there's another one
here thank you okay that's the long one
nothing happened there maybe it's this
one great love it finally oh I don't
know why I didn't save it let me find it
oh this the real oj has stabbed you I
got tackled by it yo is there is there
really no difference between a capital A
and a lowercase L I experimented with it
it's pretty much impossible to tell that
was he responsible that is yes the can
we closely examine that video and see
because I collected after that guy sent
me the email I looked at it pretty
carefully and I mean he's got a point it
would be easy to fake you think so yeah
that guy sounded like such a bozo but
maybe that's his power
cuz he's like nobody will suspect right
very unassuming or whatever I don't know
though yeah I'm I just thought we should
acknowledge the possibility all right
sure I don't want AJ coming after ya you
know he may not have sent a knife emoji
in the D abs and finally for our finals
story here a little light-hearted ending
to our story nearly 100 drivers follow
to Google Maps detour and ended up stuck
in an empty field here on 64th Avenue in
Aurora there's more birds and bullet
holes than people on a road that is
certainly less traveled until Sunday
take exit 286 onto Tower Road a car
crash on Pena Boulevard caused some GPS
apps like Google Maps to detour drivers
onto 64th Khan Iman C's was one of that
was supposed to be half the time and her
husband was already waiting at the
airport but then the route got weird and
it spit us out onto a dirt road and
about a hundred other cars kept going my
thought was well all these other cars
are in front of me so it must be okay so
I just continued however with the wet
weather over the weekend that road got
muddy and slick and that's when I
thought oh this was a bad dish so
actually what they're saying now that
I'm now realizing is that that road was
legit it's just the conditions were too
bad for many cars between the mud and to
those cars started getting stuck did
Google send us out there because it's a
shortcut and it just didn't make any
sense there was no turning back once you
were there honey by the way is related
to our traffic expert Jason I'm not
gonna lie I problem apps to the center
of the ocean dude you know what I mean
you'd pull a Michael Scott like that's
yeah I would drive it I mean dude it's
so hard navigating these cities I don't
know anybody did it before coop like
navigation I mean la is a hellhole who
could ever navigate this city without
navigation you gotta get on that ways
game you know Google Maps bot way it's
the same [ __ ] before Google Maps it was
all the Thomas guide do you remember
Thomas guide it's an LA MapQuest oh this
is this is pre MapQuest even what was
Thomas guide it was a giant [ __ ] book
of maps oh yeah and everybody had on a
car what is this the Oregon Trail mother
folks were pulling over it with maps in
their car yeah there was an index
in the back to look up streets and my
very first job was a PA I was a driver
and it was before MapQuest was useful
and [ __ ] actually no there was MapQuest
but I would I would occasionally I would
get called and told hey you need to go
to this new place and there's no
smartphones or anything so I just I pull
out the book look up the [ __ ] Street
and like plan a route the jam yeah how
much productivity have we gained from
that [ __ ] you know ya know I'm real nice
there's no going back now
but yeah I remember like going on a
family vacation like interstate and my
parents are trying to use a map they're
all arguing they went down the wrong
road they turn around we're [ __ ] lost
in the lonoa yep you know been in that
car to me dude I would totally I will
follow Google Maps and to goddamn to to
go into the spit of the Grand Canyon
[ __ ] that I'll Drive off the side of the
road into the ocean I don't give a [ __ ]
I'll follow Google Maps Allah and like
those girls in kimonos falling around
Kim Kardashian I will follow Google Maps
to the end oh that's it guys no my wife
that's all we got
that's the show that's the show so Beth
Bell if you're out there we want to
sniff your farts Oh Jay if you're out
there forgive us please don't come after
me with the knife emojis I didn't do
this today church drummers out there
keep slamming Jays station we got to get
you a show channeling the dead and I
hope if I die young I hope J station
channels me on a Ouija board and I plug
his birch
that's like guys if I die before my time
I'll send you a message from beyond the
grave
I will sent a message through je station
promoting his merch and that's how you
know that the afterlife is real that's
my message for the world
Gilda cringy Oh get off the stage Justin
Trudeau saving the world one box water
at a time Kim K destroying the world I
mean Kim K has done more harm to the
world I would say then than most people
dude she is she is destroying young
girls self-esteem and self-image I mean
she is a ravaging yep the cultural
fabric of society and oh she got one
person wrongfully convicted out of
prison big deal
no I'm kidding that is a big deal that
is a big deal it was closer to a hundred
just to clearly he's got a cut oh she
got a hundred people out yeah she get a
hundred people oh she's Kim K the whole
team that she's working with are you
[ __ ] serious she got a hundred people
out yeah she's doing some good at the
White House have to help he rapes
buddies she says go ahead Ian she was
just at the White House helping this
program to give convicts access
transportation I got a piece so you not
use that truck ever again
I agree that drop is pretty misleading
as it sounds like he said it
all right songs almost over
that's alright guys thank you for
watching I kid you guys backstage in you
know I love you you're the best I love
having you here you're terrific Zak I
love you you're getting better at the
sound effects and you're willing to do
goddamn anything which is just such an
asset on the show love it Dan
come on you know the show wouldn't be
where it is now without you
you're a great present you're great a
company on the on the mic you are a
great producer you get things done and
you're a sweet guy all the same and
you've been a fan for a long time so
that's used for me I mean goddamn I'm
insecure so I knew people that like you
know
like what I do around me I'm like Ian
but I like them all the same yeah um
I'll hold it against them and finally to
bail which I will say thank you for
following me on Twitter I know you only
follow two other people and that means a
lot to me and I would like to see you
jam that dead octopus up your vagina no
don't do it no and to send me one of his
tentacles along with that and that mason
jar full of farts and Zach will eat it
okay Zach all right that's it anything
for the show Thank You Zach that's
that's what I want to hear anything for
the show
Dannan in zach you're promoted you're
the new producer in charge now you guys
are the best I love you thanks for being
here
I really do love you appreciate you guys
no show next week oh yeah no show last
week thank you or take a live or the
July off it'll be great actually I get
to spend some time with the family and
just have a week off maybe make a HD
video so I so there's no podcast next
week up you'll enjoy your fourth of July
celebrate the beautiful freedoms that we
do have in this god blessed country you
know God gave us the right to blow [ __ ]
up the [ __ ] up okay in Saudi Arabia I'd
probably be crucified for smelling
Bella's farts right that's got to be a
crime against God but in America I can
do that
god bless america well we have two weeks
to get her farts in a mason jar so
that's good and hopefully some shape
where this dude is gonna be so lit two
weeks so we'll see you then guys have a
great weekend we love appreciate you so
much and I will see you next time Tata
appreciate you god bless
[Music]